y llegó el momento de hablar de economía
en france 24 estamos con jorge hurtado
nuestro periodista especializado en el
tema jorge bienvenido y comencemos
hablando del anuncio que hizo renault a
fabricante de automóviles de suspender
sus operaciones en rusia así es que
bueno para esta empresa francesa rusia
es su segundo mercado más importante la
suspensión de actividades será vigente a
partir de hoy cerrando su fábrica de
moscú donde se ensamblan tres modelos de
renault el captura el 23 arcana ahí
también se ensambla el modelo terrano de
sus socios de nissan ayer total energy
sse que había sido muy criticada por
seguir haciendo negocios en rusia
también suspendió sus actividades
renault dijo que evaluará su
participación en las dos unidades de
apto base y será responsable de los
45.000 empleados que tiene en rusia
solamente el año pasado renault vendió
en rusia el 18 por ciento de todos sus
vehículos y ese país representa
aproximadamente el 10 por ciento del
total de su facturación y otra de las
noticias en rusia es que moscú anunció
que cobrará el gas en rublos a los
países no amigos qué significa bueno
esta medida es una respuesta de parte de
moscú a las sanciones de occidente por
su invasión en ucrania rusia creó una
lista de países y territorios
inamistosos que incluye a eeuu canadá a
todos los países miembros de la unión
europea reino unido ucrania suiza
albania japón está allí también en corea
del sur australia singapur taiwán entre
otros putin afirmó que tanto estados
unidos como la unión europea han
declarado un incumplimiento real de sus
obligaciones con rusia escuchemos parte
de lo que dijo y
es obvio que en este contexto no tiene
ningún sentido que suministramos
nuestras mercancías tanto la unión
europea como estados unidos y que
recibamos el pago en dólares euros u
otras monedas
así que he decidido aplicar un conjunto
de medidas de pagos de transferencia en
un plazo muy corto
dwight complex en el período actual
empezaremos por transferir a rublos
rusos los pagos por nuestros suministros
de gas natural a los llamados países no
amigos esto significa abandonar el uso
de todas las monedas comprometidas en
estos pagos
rubli twist
y mientras tanto la unión europea está
buscando reemplazar el suministro ruso
con energía canadiense así es bueno en
total el occidente está buscando también
cómo se apliquen todas las sanciones
contra rusia por la invasión en ucrania
canadá y el bloque europeo estudiarán la
posibilidad de aumentar el suministro de
energía canadiense a los 27 para reducir
su dependencia de los combustibles
fósiles rusos según la presidente de la
comisión europea se la va a poner line y
la funcionaria y el primer ministro
canadiense josh centro do se reunirán
esta noche en bruselas donde llegaron
para la cumbre de la otan y del g7 que
se realiza mañana en la capital belga y
que abordará específicamente la
situación de ucrania el gas ruso supone
el 40 por ciento del consumo total de la
unión europea y las materias primas se
mantienen al alza frente a una posible
interrupción de este suministro pero
rusia afirma que seguirán suministrando
gas acorde a los volúmenes y precios
estipulados en los contratos que ya
están vigentes y en italia sigue el
ministerio por el el megayate que podría
pertenecer al presidente ruso así es el
este yate de nombre escher asad se
encuentra bajo investigación en la
costera toscana además a la policía
financiera de italia mantiene abierta
esta investigación sobre la propiedad
del yate valorado en 700 millones de
dólares varios yates propiedades del
garcas ruso ya han sido incautados en
europa desde que moscú invadió ucrania
el mes pasado pero de comprobarse el
vínculo de este yate con el presidente
ruso sería la incautación más grande el
yate por ejemplo cuenta con dos
helipuertos una piscina una sala de cine
esto según el sitio de web súper jacques
está la fundación anticorrupción del
disidente ruso alexéi navalni publicó un
video en youtube atribuyendo este yate a
putin el presidente ucraniano 2000
selenski pidió a italia que confiscar a
todos los activos financieros que se
encuentran en ese país incluidos los
yates impresionado de los datos que nos
da del yate y terminemos con los
indicadores bueno la bolsa de eeuu
volvieron a caer desanimadas por la
falta de acuerdos para una salida
pacífica en ucrania en europa las
acciones cayeron también después de
haber tocado máximo de un mes al
principio de la sesión ya que la subida
de los precios del petróleo se sumó a la
preocupación por el impacto económico de
la crisis de ucrania y en américa latina
la bolsa mexicana de valores
10 2 % en su principal indicador
rompiendo una racha de cinco sesiones
que mantuvo al alza gracias jorge por
esta información y a ustedes los
invitamos a que sigan conectados con
france24
[Música]
ah